welcome back to uncensored yes JK
standing in for the big dog as he
lounges in the sun we're working our
backsides off now let's move on the
backlash against the so-called woke Snow
White remake continues to grow as the
son of the original film's director says
his dad and Walt Disney would be turning
in their graves at the proposed changes
and for those not following this Saga
let me fill you in firstly you sitting
comfortably then I'll begin
[Music]
it all started when the character of
Snow White so-called and the original
cartoon because her skin was white as
snow was given to Rachel zegler a Latino
actress
then behind the scenes pictures were
released that showed the iconic Seven
Dwarves have been replaced by seven
mostly averagely sized magical creatures
and finally in a Twist none of us saw
coming the new Snow White actress
claimed that Prince Charming was well
just a weird creepy stalker whose scenes
could well be cut from the final film
The End
all of this comes as Disney reported 900
million dollars worth of losses in
August alone after a series of woke
releases tanked at the box office so my
question tonight is should the new Snow
White be put to sleep and scrapped or
can it still have a happy ever after I
cannot wait for this segment joining me
now is journalist and author of the case
for Council culture you try saying that
Ernest Owens and the author in Babylon B
contribute to Ashley Saint Claire uh
good evening one and all um Earnest
you're a massive massive Disney fan
um do you think Uncle Walt would be
spinning in his grave at this uh well I
don't know how you describe it this um
remake of a classic
absolutely not I think that one of the
things that Disney did well with his
films was that he remade his own
versions of films of classic Disney
films I mean really fairy tales that
made a more Americanized for the
audiences and I think that this is just
in the Disney tradition
um and I always tell people that don't
like this version or they they're
suspicion anymore like it listen you can
go to Disney plus and you can watch the
1939 version Snow White and the comfort
of your own bedroom into your eyes bleed
but for some of us like myself I look
forward to seeing this new reimagining
of sunlight and I think so many people
need to just give it a shot
um can can I just say Ashley and I I'm
probably you know I'm a bit
old-fashioned I'm nearly 60. even older
than peers
um
I just find suddenly Prince Charming's a
stalker suddenly Everything's changed
and and whilst whilst I understand that
the world has changed you know my
daughters and my kids tell me I'm I'm an
old bugger and whatever but isn't It's
just sad that everything
seriously actually is going to be
scrapped the
symptomatic of a world is it not that
says that anything classic is rubbish
and we should modernize everything
they're hijacking our childhoods I'm not
sure why they're even calling it Snow
White at this point you're gonna have no
love story you're changing the Seven
Dwarfs to seven diverse magical beings I
think it's an absolute atrocity to
hijack our childhoods in her place for
this this facade of progress and as you
know Disney's doing this just to be
quote unquote Progressive when they're
the least Progressive company out there
it's all a facade as you know they were
cowing and loudly and obnoxiously
complaining about Florida's don't say
gay Bill while simultaneously cutting
scenes about a man going on a date with
another man for the release of Avengers
end game in Russia
um I have to tell I've got a great clip
uh Piers Morgan interviewed
um Dylan one of the dwarfs have a watch
behind the scenes pictures from Disney's
live-action remaker Snow White release
this weekend and there appears to be a
sizable problem where are the dwarfs
these are rules made for actors of my
stature I can't go out for the Harrison
Ford or the George Clooney roles because
that's not for me right and now it's
taken away
it I don't feel that's right
Ernest come on answer that the poor
man's not gonna get a job now man
because they've gone so woke
well I think that the reality of
diversity in film is that that actor
should actually be able to have other
roles that is not for the Seven Dwarfs I
mean you look at you know Game of
Thrones you look at some of these other
yeah but he's not going to play Tom
Cruise and you know he's not going to be
in Top Gun is he and he's saying that in
the role I want it but but why not you
know I think that there was a time where
people that looked like me couldn't even
be superheroes and we saw the world
evolve around that so I think that what
we need to stop doing is reinforcing
stereotypes about the limitations of
what Disney films can be what diversity
can look like in cinema and just get
with it because at one point you're
wondering why where are the roles for
people like him but then you're not
considering where are the roles for
people of color to be in films like Snow
White you're saying saying Miss Sinclair
that oh your childhood is being hijacked
no it's not you can go do Disney plus
and be nostalgic and watch all of those
old films if you want to but some of us
want to be in the current area but
here's my point here's my point and I
was only here for one night only I'm
allowed to give it I say this to my
daughters the whole time Ernest and you
and I are going to have this out and
Ashley can smile I absolutely accept I
absolutely accept that you have
different opinions and you want to
change things but what I will never
accept is that your generation want to
trash everything that's classic and
everything that I believed it no no let
me have my say from my childhood
everything is trash everything is
non-diverse and it's wrong why can't we
both live in the same world
because part of your role was
problematic cultural vandalism can I say
can I say to you I didn't have rights I
have rights too but I agree with you
what was problem what was problematic
about snow white though Ernest and what
they do when they they pretend that this
is all for female progress and whatever
and what they do is they actually end up
erasing women we saw this with the
remake of Mulan right the original Mulan
had a powerful story arc she persevered
through willpower and strength and in
the remake she's just giving superpowers
can I jump in ladies and gentlemen can I
just say something by the way Ernest and
you need to know this apparently Prince
Charming right uh is is a demonstration
of True Love on the one hand or he's a
creepy stalker if he hadn't kissed her
she'd still be dead Earnest Snow White
wouldn't be alive
it's time to reimagine what consent
looks like in films in 2023 period
period just write a number
off to be snow white why do you have to
remake Snow White
because that's fun let's be artistically
creative and here's the thing it's gonna
google
about taking a story
it's going to be great at the box office
well you're going to look at this and
laugh you're giving all this great
problems it's not gonna be great at the
box office in a
in another box office flops with their
woke films like light year and the
Little Mermaid this is going to be a
flop too and the numbers are showing it
and it's all a facade of progress I mean
that's an interesting point Ernest
Disney's losing billions with this woke
agenda
I don't think so I think
right here
hold on let's be clear it's not a walk
agenda I can tell you why light year did
not do well because I think in America
we're over I think a lot of that Toy
Story remakes that's why I think light
year didn't do well do you want to talk
about blue I think the Little Mermaid
did okay I think it did modestly well in
my opinion but you have to acknowledge
that there were people who had a
different agenda against Ariel being a
black character and that racism was
undeniable and that's what drove it I
don't think racism is going to play a
role but Snow White as much and I think
it's going to be successful but I think
this has been the highlights yeah Barbie
was too woke and now it's the highest
grossing film for Warner Brothers Studio
so the far right keep pushing their
agenda all they want but the numbers
show that people are interested in
seeing diverse characters there will be
hits there will be misses but that
doesn't mean that there's not a chance
if I could if I could if I could sum up
I I you know my role is to listen to
both sides nothing wrong with diversity
completely agree with you Earnest but I
also agree with Ashley when she says we
shouldn't destroy cancel obliterate and
slag off everything that has come from
before we will agree to disagree thank
you both very much